okay Jennifer Lopez four years later
more ice age I want to take you back to
yes I think they're gonna love that I'm
very excited about sharing that moment
with them once you have kids those you
know your life is a movie an animated
movie a cartoon every day and every
night it's absolutely true nothing's
changed and you know what years later
saying they're eight which is amazing
what are they really into now they
they're into their electronics you know
they're into movies they're into
animated films animated television shows
and specific ones I don't remember so
many frozen like in watched over number
shows it was years ago it was you know
why do they want to see Ice Age the
dynasty Ice Age
all the icy movies are about family and
about evolution and how families change
and they have to change the mom of two
who once again plays the saber-tooth
Tiger ascend Ice Age collision course is
all about family even dedicating a song
nightly to her twins Max and Emmy during
her Vegas residency at Planet Hollywood
I came to your show it's so incredible
and think the most touching moment is
when you give that tribute to them thank
you I wanted to seem to know what to do
something that they would look back on
those little old mommy saying that they
were like is she crying I'm like almost
every night thank you